next we have Celeste Fralick dr. Fralick
is responsible for Intel security groups
technical strategy related to analytics
that integrate into the Intel security
corporate products she brings 36 years
of industry experience to the analytics
ETO position 21 of those with Intel she
has a PhD in biomedical engineering from
Arizona State University concentrating
on predictive analytics and neuroscience
welcome good afternoon everybody hear me
okay good this wireless thing is like a
cold stethoscope so I start squealing
I'd like to thank a Wolfram for inviting
me today I appreciate it and this talk
will be probably a bit beneath you but
I'm hoping that you'll be able to take
something away from it particularly
being able to tell the fake data
scientists what we need to do
differently and there's a lot of them
out there and we'll will address that so
I wanted to share with you why now why
you should care the product life cycle
I'll introduce the PLC as well as agile
some select recommended content and
finally a summary but why now well of
course all of you know about Moore's law
and Gordon Moore there and the number of
transistors will double every 18 to 24
months and of course we're all connected
right and of course the explosion of
data so every everything i'm sure you're
probably very aware of here but what i
thought was interesting was the that i
found being a biomedical engineer and
not working in that particular field
very much anymore but i did find that a
gram of DNA is actually can
theoretically hold about 450 5 exabytes
which I thought was phenomenal so if
you're in that particular area I'd love
to talk to you there
some interesting research going on in
there but as you can see the explosion
of data connected and certainly the
power and of Moore's Law is bringing us
all together in this this changing data
and of course I spent quite a bit of
time looking to see if we might have any
more updated data than this wonderful
report a number of years ago from
Mackenzie and this indicated that there
was a 60-percent gap relative as a
supply of data scientists and I thought
surely brings to be back to the airplane
movie doesn't it don't call me Shirley
so surely it's been improved by now
right surely but I haven't been able to
find anything in fact what I did find
was a number of people said that there
wasn't a problem anymore and so I did a
little more searching and there was a
gentleman from CEO of Newtonian I I
don't know if he's here or not but he
said there is still a significant gap
and I'm going to go with that so living
in that world of data as we do it at my
company we find that there is quite a
bit of quite a bit of issues with not
enough data scientists to go around I
added this because and I didn't circle
biomedical engineer i wish i would have
but there's mathematician statistician
and data scientist i'm also trained
statistician okay and i'm a data
scientist as well but there's the best
jobs in the united states and it was a
little scary to hear 36 years in the
industry and that doesn't count what i
did while I was going through school so
that's that's kind of scary I don't know
if I'll live to see the result of the
best jobs but I love what I do and
certainly we've had a enjoyable time
taking Moore's law and taking the
connectivity and the data and bringing
them all together for incredible
intelligence
but why are there so many fake data
scientists it drives me crazy and it's
one of the things I harp on quite a bit
particularly if I apologize to all the
computer scientists out there but
particularly computer scientists who
have not been trained I'm sorry you can
attack me later particularly who haven't
been trained in statistics so I did
notice this particular and I stole this
from a from a spite and I should have
used my own because actually what I had
instead advanced analytics with
statistics and I as I said I am a
trained statistician but I do worry that
data scientists and computer scientists
aren't typically trained in and
statistics and one of the things i found
was that when I had a young lady come up
to me and I and she said I have a
wonderful correlation in the product
being moved in a retail space from this
point to this point and that point to
that point I said really what did you do
she says I used XYZ tool and I said
that's great I said you found a
correlation that's great what was their
correlation coefficient she said what
and I said do not know the distribution
of your data in order to select your
correlation coefficient she goes no I
didn't do that i just plugged my numbers
in and I have to tell you I find that
constantly and it drives me absolutely
batty and you don't want to see me go
batty but you know Tom Davenport from
babson college he indicated that
in the hbr article that data scientist
is a sexy title there's a demand for
media business intelligence and action
and of course one I was given a couple
years ago was give me an idea of how
these HVAC saan top of a theater are
actually talking to one another with 300
different variables each and I want it
in a week and I said do you not
understand eighty percent of the time is
spent cleaning the data and he said I
don't care I need it now the customer
needs it now so there's a lot of
management pressure for it immediate
action without understanding the process
there are too many areas to learn
certainly we have data scientists that
are experts and data management software
development and maybe not all of them
there's too few data scientists as we
indicated supply and demand and it's an
ill-defined job role and there's an easy
to learn mentality without underlying
statistical fundamentals I can't tell
you how many Millennials come to me as a
technical leader of a very large company
and they come to me and they ask I want
to be a data scientist what do I have to
do can I take a class and i'll be done
this it it's more than that it's more
than that so what can we do to help them
what can we do to make them feel a
little bit more at home and a little bit
more competent at what they do so we put
together the waterfall product lifecycle
I'm sure you're all very familiar with
it but what we did was we as you're all
familiar with the waterfall product
lifecycle yes no yes okay so it's pretty
common there's all kinds of different
life cycles but what we did was we lined
up the analytic process of defying usage
model and problem framing an analytic
risk assessment that you take throughout
the entirety of the of the flow we
define the requirements of course trace
back to the
customer a state-of-the-art assessment
where you look at the literature many
many many of my colleagues particularly
those that just brush out of their
bachelor's there they're often running
calculating and I asked them have you
even looked at the literature it's
probably already been done and if it
hasn't then go off and do it but maybe
you can learn something I actually had
somebody talk to me about the gross a
support vector machine support the the
clusters next to the support vector
machines the hyperplane and he wanted to
understand the growth and you know where
I found a wonderful wonderful paper was
on bacterial growth using SVM totally
out of the field but when I brought it
to him he was able to understand it and
so he's got a little taste so yeah you
know I think it helps analytic plan and
peer review i'll go over that
verification and validation discover and
develop and iterate your analytics is
what we all do day in and day out the
report and peer review as well as the
post-production released analytic review
as well as the discontinuance now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go
through a couple of these so I don't
bore you silly I did want to show you
how it actually can integrate into agile
as well for those of you who do agile
and I'll review that just a little bit
in this particular messy slide so I did
want to go over the fact that when you
put an analytic plan together with a
peer review it actually helps quite a
bit to let everyone know what you're
doing and framing the problem and if
I've got it in red because how many
managers out there go we don't have time
to do all this stuff right so with an
epic you can break it down into pieces
and agile but you can also do the
analytic plan and include everything
before it so you
don't have to have you know you just
have to have a couple of reports here
state-of-the-art assessments we
discussed and as you can see there's
some purposes listed there and y'all can
read what what we go through there I did
want to share with you though that we
have a 77 page document that just
absolutely terrifies our engineers are
data scientists and I got you know it's
not that bad really there's only about
there's only about I don't know about 30
pages or so that really have the bulk of
the material and the rest is all
appendices to really help you and one in
thing in particular each section has
these purpose entrance criteria the
audience and so on the formats and the
templates are very helpful for the new
the new data scientist and so we have a
lot of help there the entrance and the
exit criteria what goes on before what
goes on when you leave it the outcomes
what do you expect at this point and
where to store the information most
people forget that we need to store the
data we need to indicate the data and if
you're working with a government entity
and I'm from the medical side i can tell
you add in the military side i can tell
you that they need that information and
working with a commercial company i can
tell you that we have legal records as
to how long we're supposed to do things
so that's very important to us as well
the analytic plan and peer review i want
to go through just a little bit to give
you an idea of things that you probably
already know so consider this just a
refresh and pass it on to the younger
data scientist coming up so what does
the customer want and why we need to
really understand what the usage model
is what the user experience is and
traceability starts here and if I can do
this I'm not sure I can we just didn't
work before and I'm not a Mac user
oh this actually speaks to framing the
problem now as you know we have a edge
or clients you know down at the sensor
level we have the nodes in the gateways
that can pass through and we have the
cloud and different types of clouds
right but we we really need to assess
the environment and frame the problem
before we get started on our honor data
science and the reason I say this is a
company that won't be mentioned has a
particular manufacturing site and
Ireland it's a very well knowing company
and we were asked to go over there we
were asked to go over there and put in
predictive analytics we got over there
and they were literally still
handwriting their entries and when they
took out their product out of their bass
they were sitting it down on the floor
and opening the door for it to dry does
anybody scared oh come on and you should
be that's kind of scary that's not the
right way to manufacture product
it didn't it was in Ireland you know
sometimes it's you know yeah who knows
but it did and then they were curious as
why everything was a different thickness
duh or why things didn't dry as well but
the point being is these guys wanted
predictive analytics oh my gosh you're
not ready for predictive analytics you
are ready for just documenting product
right so anyway be aware of the current
infrastructure the desired
infrastructure certainly the data being
collected where they are in their
maturity and this is just a sample list
of questions we actually have about a
hundred of them but be aware that there
are limitations with their latency and
as well as their bandwidth see if I
could do this again I am NOT a Mac users
this is just so bizarre okay so
traceability start with traceability
list start start tracing and listing
every one of the the user requirements
here and hopefully it'll work no it
didn't all right so it didn't know but
the analytic risk assessment continued
it throughout the development understand
your sources of error one of the things
that I find with the young engineers is
they don't list the sources of error nor
do they put down a mitigation plan it's
something that you do on a routine basis
a routine basis as a statistician always
the cost-benefit ratio I have a current
manager right now that would like to see
how one person does their security
because I'm an Intel security one of the
things they want to look at is the URLs
that they're going to and then use that
same type of analytic out
them for the next person so there's a
cost-benefit ratio with that how much do
they want to spend doing that algorithm
how much space do they want to look at
cache memory challenges I like iso 4971
does anybody there's an FDA person in
here somewhere is there anybody that's
familiar with this particular spec
anybody oh good thank you it's kind of
bright out there it is an awesome spec I
love 4971 I really do yeah it's a pain
in the butt but me and you go through it
once and you'll be an expert at it
because it helps you understand what all
the hazards of your product art doesn't
have to be medical you can apply that to
just about anything define requirements
right up front sample size acceptance
criteria output the state-of-the-art
assessment we talked about plan includes
the intense the hypothesis the targeted
p value and all of this other stuff that
i won't go over but at least you get the
idea of the fact that start with the
planning and please list it to begin
with and take the time to understand the
problem i'm actually working with
somebody now that has worked on the
problem for about a year and I finally
stopped and said you know you because I
just came into this particular group and
I said can you please frame the problem
and fill out this and he was shocked at
some of the information he did not know
and it changed the way he approached his
problem so discover develop and iterate
analytics I'm it's not building it's
there we go well alright so as I don't
have a oops sorry I built on a PC and
it's been transferred to a Mac so I
think Apple for that you're all familiar
i'm sure with the Gartner foil be aware
that we have reporting reactive and
proactive and you have to do
prescriptive it's like I was talking
about in Ireland we need to make sure we
do descriptive before we do diagnostic
diagnostic before predictive predictive
more prescriptive I like to look at
reporting reactive and proactive within
the descriptive and diagnostic and of
course I'm sure you're all pretty
familiar again it's not building very
well sorry sorry it supposed to be a
build here but this is a general process
of analytics I'm sure we all have done
that the takeaway here is please do your
basic statistics first it's really
really important to understand the
distribution of your data and to
understand the relationship of the data
and and finally you can certainly get
into system evaluation and what I've
done here is even though it's not a not
a linear process it helps to explain to
the new data scientists exactly what you
should go through instead of just
running right into a tool without doing
your basics first so again this is all
helping us to weed out those data
scientists or the fake data scientists
or better yet make them a good data
scientist so we get good data this is
another one if you didn't like that last
one this is the crisp damn model that
I'm sure you're all familiar with but
the one thing I learned from working in
the medical for so many years and i'm
hoping the fda person or the medical
person will appreciate this is that
we've we've taken validation and
verification and we've brought it into
the to the development of of analytics
and an easy way to remember this is have
you done the right analytic is
validation verification is have you done
the analytic right so have you done the
right analytic will trace back to your
customer and again here comes those
codes that you use to trace from user to
requirement to result and the
verification really talks about have you
done your model right have you done the
mathematics right many folks that I've
dealt with have
on svms and SVM's only that's all they
look at and I said have you looked at
the rock have the receiver operating
characteristic curve have you looked at
the r-squared have you looked at the
conference limps have you looked at all
of these other things and they go well
no it just said it works so I asked them
to please look at some other things
other models i will look at anywhere
from three to five models on every
project i use and if you don't please do
there's a legal issue of doing
validation and verification you need to
document your validation and
verification and produce all the graphs
and all the data that you've done at
this point from a legal perspective it
really helps with mergers and
acquisitions if you do an acquisition of
a vey company that has a fancy data
solution the first thing you should ask
them for is this information if they
don't have it you could actually be
legally liable if something say a
self-driving automobile or something
like that fails so from a legal
perspective stealing validation and
verification from the medical world is
actually very very smart but where is
all the software you say you know surely
you've got to be a software don't call
me Shirley there surely you've got to be
a software engineer right and you do
data science so you're one of those
wonderful people that merge both of them
well you can do the analytic V and V and
then you can do the software validation
and then you can do the system
evaluation you get three validations
that will just drive your manager crazy
and you won't get your your product out
real fast but there's also all right
I've decided from now four graphs that
PC to Mac builds don't work
so it was supposed to be a belt sorry so
you could do concurrence which we find
to be the most common analytic software
and system validation at the same time
or an agile approach as reflected in a
previous slide for software validation
and analytic VNV and be able to get your
software done as well as your algorithm
done as well alright the l a-- tech
report in peer review is to document the
background methods results conclusions
those of you who have written the
masters or a PhD or a paper you'll
recognize this it really should be done
in in analytics as well it's to mitigate
the fact that you've got somebody
leaving and they're right in the middle
of doing some data cleansing and they
leave for a better job or Google and the
next thing you know you're back to
square one you really need to capture
that work that they've done include the
hell why where when what and who as we
heard from Brian earlier it's really
important for the repeatability as well
as in ensuring that when somebody does
leave you know where to pick up the
pieces remember the revisions not only
of the tool that you're using but the
heart the hardware that you're using and
also the implementation constraints that
you had with with the the memory the
cash and so on and lastly the post
production release analytic review this
is a broken-down house here you don't
want that you want to make sure that
once you've done your algorithm that
it's out in the field it's working
really well you want to look at it every
so often and ask if it's still the same
the features and design space can change
data decays processes move processes
change you minimize your liability you
protect your IP and also the MA
the data flow is very important make
sure that when you do your data flow
that you capture all of the information
about the process and what's happening
mathematically to that data at the edge
at the node and at the cloud lastly to
sum up the analogue discipline will
protect you and your company as well as
your customer and so there's legal
issues repeatability issues you want to
optimize your model to do that you need
that discipline where did you start
where did you end you want to monitor
post implementation because life changes
you want to be able to help those want
to be data scientists to become better
data scientists document your process
and that way you'll be able to meet your
customer needs thank you